for a long time and beats by dre were
seen in a negative light mostly due to
the brand really investing into
marketing rather than sound quality and
going into this review we didn't have
high expectations for the beat so low
pro but they ended up surprising us here
at max tech specifically there were four
things that we found surprising about
them and I'll tell you what those are in
just a bit let's start out with a look
in the field of course looks are
subjective but we like them you have six
color options if you want something
sleek and low-key I would go for the
black but if you want to stand out the
red or the blue that we have really pop
they're mostly made of plastic that does
feel more durable than my sonís and
they're not heavy but they do have some
weight to them and do feel nice we have
thick aluminum for the adjustable
headband and also for the hinge which by
the way seems very durable with this
thick aluminum and it also functions to
turn the beats on and off the fact that
they turn on automatically when you
unfold them is really convenient kind of
like how air pods work when you take
them out of the case that also means
that you need to remember to fold them
up to turn them off but once you get
used to this feature having to turn on
other headphones becomes a little bit
annoying we can really see apples
influence here with this feature but
that doesn't stop there we have the h1
chip that does a bunch of things if you
have an iPhone having them close
together will trigger a pop-up making
pairing super easy and once you do the
solos will show up on your other devices
if you have iCloud enabled because
everything is integrated you don't need
a download an app everything is built-in
so holding down on the volume slider in
the control center will allow you swap
between the different modes but more on
that later this deep integration goes
all the way to the charging port where
we unfortunately find a lightning
connector instead of a USB type-c which
we would prefer the solos don't have a
physical headphone port so if you want
to use them wired you will need to buy
Apple's $35 lining two three-and-a-half
millimeter cable where that Jack used to
be we now have a button that lets you
toggle between modes and holding it down
will let you pair to other Bluetooth
devices one thing I want to know is that
Android users can download the beats app
to get information and switch between
modes as well on the right side we have
hidden
cool controls the controls are basically
the same as on the air pod pros pressing
up and down adjust the volume and
pressing down on the center less you
pause skip go back pick up calls and
more depending on how many times you
press holding down will invoke your
assistant but with iOS you could just
say hey Siri instead where it can be
very convenient if your hands are busy
or dirty or whatever the controls work
but we do wish that beats made use of
their right side and the left side to
control tracks instead of using the
center button for everything now let's
get into comfort which completely
depends on the person these are on your
headphones and not everybody is into
that to begin with but then you add the
strong clamping force and that could
make them uncomfortable for people that
have larger heads this clamping force is
needed for a strong seal but thankfully
both the rubber headband and the ear
cups are very comfortable the ear cups
are made from soft memory foam and that
really helps with comfort and provides a
good seal that is needed for the noise
cancellation this also results in the
second surprise and that's how little
sound leak they have even with volume
maxed out to the max where they could be
even too loud for people like me who
love loud music there is almost no sound
that escapes we literally haven't used
any headphones that seal sound in so
well I'm serious about this even if you
max them out and your ears are starting
to hurt from the volume somebody just
next to you can barely hear anything
just a little bit of the high notes and
everything else is sealed out and then
if you drop them to about 85% volume
which is more than enough and sounds
great a person just two feet away can't
hear anything at all now if you don't
like on ear headphones then the solo
pros most likely are not going to change
your mind and over ear headphones are
definitely more comfortable than on your
headphones especially if you use them
for more than say two three or four
hours at a time but I use these for over
two hours maybe about two and a half
hours and it did result and a little bit
of pressure built up but not enough to
make me feel like I have to take them
off like I have felt with other on ears
if you've used other on ear headphones
and don't mind them and you have an
average-sized head these should be
totally fine
next is sound quality which really
surprised me I own the really popular
Sony WH 1000 XM 3s and to me and the
beats actually sound better
previously beats are known for being
very bass heavy and lacking clarity but
possibly thanks to Apple these sounds
the exact opposite basses presence and
very tight and accurate without taking
over the mids and the high frequencies
are very clear in fact with some tracks
like rock songs the high notes can
actually be a little bit too sharp if
the volume is maxed out but for that we
found not turning down the volume just
one notch on the iPhone which is about
seven percent or so really helps but
with most tracks especially those worth
heavy vocals and high notes like
electronics these sound very good
of course sound is subjective but what
is this objective is that these beats
sound way more balanced than any
previous Beats headphones that I've
listened to and in a few songs that I
really like I noticed some of the sound
effects some of the electronic effects
that were kind of subdued with my other
headphones and blended into the mids
whereas because of the really good
high-frequency clarity those really
start to stand out now let's get into
noise cancellation and this was our
final surprise with these headphones
everybody knows that these Sony's are
top-of-the-line but honestly we didn't
hear that much of a difference between
them our office is located right next
door to their furnace room so we have a
constant low-frequency droning noise and
these get rid of them completely just
like the Sony's I didn't get a chance to
fly with them so we don't know how they
would compare to the Sony's in that
location but in normal use they are
shockingly close we thought that for
most people the noise cancellation of
the air pod pros are more than good
enough and the beats solo pros are
definitely better with low-end and
dramatically better with high frequency
sounds so we think that for the large
majority of people they will be very
happy with the beats solo pros another
major feature is the ambient mode which
uses the mics to let you hear your
environment and just like the previously
mentioned ear pods this feature sounds
much more natural than other brands that
we have tested
which tend to sound digital battery life
is great with about 20 hours of use with
either noise cancellation or am memo
turned on or about 40 hours with it off
in 10 minutes of fast charging gives you
about 3 hours of use I need to be
completely honest with you guys
I kind of came into this review a bit
biased against Beats headphones but
trying them out for the first time and
then for a few days after that I am way
more impressed and I like these way more
than I expected and after using them
overall I would highly recommend them if
you're looking for a pair of on your
headphones that are premium at that
price point and you want that really
nice noise cancellation overall the
whole package really makes sense if you
can afford them and the sound quality is
really good thank you guys for watching
if you want to see my comparison against
the Sony's
you guys can check that out right over
there and click above to subscribe and
down below to enable notifications this
has been max with Max tech and I will
see you in the next video
[Music]